[Music]
hello everybody uh thank you so much for
inviting me and thank you for staying
all the way to the last talk on a
three-day conference I know that it is
very hard to keep the energy going all
the way to the end of a conference and
the very end of the day this has been a
great conference I want to thank the
organizers the staff the volunteers for
an amazing conference I go to a lot of
conferences and this has been absolutely
world-class the curation of the talks
the quality of the speakers the
organization the a/v the food please
let's all give them a round of applause
[Applause]
and before we get started we have to do
the pre talk speaker selfie because if
it doesn't end up on Instagram did it
even happen
all right with that important business
out of the way hello I'm Laurie I helped
co-found NPM Inc I didn't invent NPM I
just did all of the other stuff and I'm
currently chief data officer there but
what I really AM is a web developer I've
been a web developer for 23 years now
which means that I have been writing
HTML longer than some of you have been
alive but making the web bigger and
better and more accessible by getting
more people involved that is what really
motivates me and I know that you were
all expecting a talk about the future of
JavaScript but at the last minute I
decided I would just throw the whole
thing out and instead this talk is gonna
be about micro front ends
[Music]
can you even imagine this is just a joke
for like the five people who spend way
too much time on Twitter and will
understand this joke what I'm really
here to talk about is JavaScript I'm
gonna talk about who we are we the
people who write JavaScript where we use
JavaScript and what we're doing with it
today and I'm also going to talk about
why we're doing this stuff the forces
that got JavaScript and us into where we
are today and then finally I'm going to
talk about what comes next I'm gonna
look at all of the trends that we're
seeing and make some guesses about where
it's going the goal of this talk is to
give you a sense of where you are in the
landscape of JavaScript and where your
current tools and techniques sit in that
landscape because too many developers
work in a sort of vacuum you don't know
if the stuff that you're doing is a best
practice or if it's a fad or if it's
this outdated technique that nobody does
anymore too many people are like I'm
gonna do this thing and I hope it's okay
but we know and we should be able to
share that information with you so I
hope you'll leave this talk feeling good
about one thing that you're using and
realizing it's time to move away from
one other thing that you're using and
also curious and excited about learning
one new thing but before I say all of
this stuff it's worth asking how we know
all of this stuff I have three main
sources first the NPM registry logs
every time you download a package we see
it happen they contain an enormous
amount of information about what
JavaScript developers are up to second
we went out and asked people directly
two years ago we did a survey of 16,000
JavaScript developers and last year we
did a bigger one of 33,000 JavaScript
developers and asked you directly like
what are you using and why and I also
supplemented and double-checked our
numbers using the excellent state of
JavaScript survey run by independent
members of the community incidentally
while this talk is strictly about
JavaScript if you are interested in
warren CSS the same people who did the
state of javascript survey this year for
the first time did a state of CSS survey
and it's full of fun
Meishan about what is going on in the
world of CSS and the website is an
absolute nightmare CSS transitions
because they just threw in everything
that they could possibly do and before
we dive in a few quick disclaimers some
of what I'm presenting here is facts and
some of what I'm presenting here is
opinions and I've tried to be as clear
as possible about when I'm doing which
one of those things sometimes people see
a graph that I present that says that a
technology that they love is getting
less popular and then they get mad at me
and what I'm asking you to do is I have
a bunch of really terrible opinions get
mad about the opinions don't get mad
about the graph the graph is just a
thing you can't get mad at it it's just
happening I don't have a horse in this
race other than NPM I don't contribute
to any of the projects that I'm talking
about so I'm not I'm trying to you know
just present the facts without any bias
here but all facts have bias secondly a
lot of what I'm talking about involves
relative popularity of technologies and
I want to make clear but just because
the technology is popular that doesn't
mean that I think it's the best
technology in fact I don't even know
what the best technology means Evan you
and his talk yesterday gave a really
great description of the sort of space
that frameworks in particular live in
it's this sort of multi-dimensional
space where you can't even know what's
best there is no best there's just you
know trade-offs that you make in all
sorts of directions so for technology
popularity is useful if there are a lot
of people using your technology then
there gonna be a lot of blog posts a lot
of tutorials a lot of questions answered
on Stack Overflow there will be a lot of
people helping find and fix bugs so if
you work with something that's very
popular it often makes your work easier
regardless of you know how good that
technology is by you know whatever
definition of good you want to use so
popularity is what I have data about and
popularity is what I'm talking about but
I'm not saying that things are better
and finally I really love this stuff and
I'd have to get very excited about this
stuff and when I get excited I cursed
like a drunken sailor
and there's just nothing I intend to do
about that so you're all just going to
have to deal so who are we
JavaScript developers the answer is
we're pretty much like all developers at
this point when we said that when we set
out to get these questions I was like oh
well I'm expecting JavaScript developers
to be different demographically in some
way maybe we're younger maybe we work on
different stuff now it turns out that
almost everybody who is a programmer
gets to do JavaScript these days and so
we look like all other programmers we
have the same age distribution the same
levels of education we work in every
industry and in every country in the
world and the reason is there are just
so many of us there are 11 million
JavaScript developers in 2019 and those
11 million developers are using more
open source software than any other
language community has ever used before
the NPM registry is the largest
repository of open-source software of
any kind and by any measure by number of
modules by lines of code by number of
users whatever measure you want to pick
it is more than twice as big as the
next-biggest registry of course
everybody knows that javascript in
particular has a tendency to use lots of
modules so maybe that's not a fair
comparison so does having a really big
registry translate to any other kind of
activity on github javascript is the
largest language by a number of
repositories by a number of issues and
by number of lines of code and it has
been for seven years in a row on Stack
Overflow they did a survey of 80,000
developers and JavaScript was again the
most popular language with 68% of all
developers in their survey saying that
they use it of course you're all at JS
console you probably knew that
JavaScript was pretty popular but here
is the truth
javascript is the most popular
programming language in the world today
and because there are more developers in
the world today than ever before it is
the most popular programming language
that has ever existed as JavaScript
community continues to grow the
JavaScript community is changing the
JavaScript the one thing that we noticed
that's changed about us between our
survey in 2018 and the one we did last
year this year is that JavaScript
developers are getting more experienced
they've been writing JavaScript for
longer we especially noticed this with
p.m. itself a year ago half of NPM users
were what we consider new they'd been
using NPM for less than two years and
this year only 36% are round about 2014
and 2015 there was a massive spike in
the number of NPM users it was when the
existing pool of JavaScript developers
sort of latched on to the idea that NPM
was a thing that they should use and
they all showed up at once and today the
number of new NPM users and the number
of new JavaScript users is pretty much
the same basically anybody who learns
JavaScript learns NPM at the same time
and all of the people who had learned
JavaScript before NPM came along have at
this point pretty much all adopted it so
now we believe that about 99% of
JavaScript developers use NPM that's
part of why we have so much information
and it's part of why in this talk I use
the terms like NPM users or respondents
or JavaScript developers as pretty much
interchangeable because they pretty much
are this ever-growing pool of
increasingly experienced JavaScript
developers means that we've seen a shift
in what people care about we knew from
analyzing last year's data when we cut
people up by how long they've been doing
JavaScript that more experienced
developers care more about best
practices they knew do more bundling
they do more lending they care more
about security the care about they care
more about everything and because all of
javascript is becoming more experienced
that's now true of all JavaScript
developers as a whole since last year's
survey the number of people concerned
about the security of their open source
has increased in the last two years
NPM has introduced two-factor off to
help protect package publishers from
having their account stolen as well as a
security team and a bunch of automation
behind the scenes to detect and flag
malicious packages but malicious
packages while they get a lot of press
they're not really the biggest source of
security vulnerabilities the biggest
source of security vulnerabilities is
accidental vulnerabilities
vulnerabilities caused by you using a
package with a known security
vulnerability and not updating your
dependencies so last year we introduced
the end
audit command which will find and fix
security vulnerabilities in your
application by upgrading to a more
secure version of that package in the
last 30 days
we have performed more than 335 million
of these audits because they happen
every time you run NPM install if you
think that your company should be doing
more about JavaScript security and it
probably should then you'll forgive me
if I spend a little time mentioning NPM
Enterprise NPM Enterprise gives you your
own registry on your own domain with
your own NPM website where you can see
what you where you're devs have
published you can publish your own
packages you can search within all of
your company's Java scripts you can see
full package pages and read Me's it's
just like having your own little NPM
universe inside of your company it
includes single sign-on support and
extra security and compliance reporting
which is the kind of stuff that big
companies need basically if you are a
big company you should probably be using
it and if you are a smaller company we
have a company we have a product called
orgs which does many of the same things
and is a lot cheaper so back to the
survey data after that terrible terrible
sales pitch
I was wearing the rainbow shirt and
there's rainbow unicorns on the stage
and I have been for the entire three
days I've been telling myself I'm gonna
do some of this talk while sitting on
the damn unicorn so that's gonna be this
section so another aspect of our
increasingly experienced user base is
that people actually care about the
software licenses that they use that was
kind of a surprise because like people
think of JavaScript developers as being
Cowboys who just like throw in
there without looking at it but it turns
out that 58% of JavaScript developers
say that the software license effects
their decision to use an open-source
package and 55% of those people say that
their company actively prevents them
from using certain software licenses so
overall 29 percent of people are
prohibited from using certain licenses
what license is exactly well
unsurprisingly the GPL and the a GPL are
unpopular because of the restrictions
that a place on commercial development
but bigger than those was
nice licenses basically anybody who
cares about licenses has to hire a
lawyer to tell them which licenses are
okay
so if you use a license that they've
never heard of they have to go back to
the lawyer and pay the lawyer more money
nobody wants to do that so if you're
releasing open source software by all
means include some kind of license but
stick to one of the big popular licenses
because otherwise people will just go
this license is too weird I will not use
it a really great example of that was
Facebook tried to change the license
that react is licensed under and like
react a very popular Facebook very large
company but even they could not get past
the battery of annoyed lawyers going no
we do not want to have to figure this
out again go back to MIT and the final
aspect of who we are that I want to
touch on is a consequence of how
ubiquitous JavaScript has become which
is that 25% of JavaScript developers
don't consider JavaScript to be their
primary language because javascript is
so popular it's becoming escapable and
because it's inescapable there's a mean
it means that there's a lot of people
who program javascript who are doing so
because they have to not because they
want to and that is going to show up in
a bunch of places in this data so what
are these other languages written by
developers who don't who Brent don't
primarily write JavaScript well the top
of the list is typescript typescript is
an interesting case and I'm gonna talk
more about it in a bit but there's also
lots of Python and Java and C and C
sharp in there and we'll see the effect
that that's having later interestingly
12% of JavaScript developers say that
javascript is the only language they
write it's just all JavaScript all the
time for 12% of you but 88% of you are
writing something else so now we've
covered who we are we are all over the
world we are every age and experience we
are increasingly sophisticated and we
care more about licensing and security
than we used to where are we writing all
of this javascript well the answer is
every goddamn place you can imagine
first and most obviously is browsers 97%
of us are writing code for browsers 77%
of us are also writing JavaScript for
servus so noches is obviously still a
big part of the JavaScript's community
but there are two big surprises in here
and the first one is native apps 46% of
JavaScript developers are writing native
apps and 13% of us are doing embedded as
I'm going to dig into all of these
numbers because they're fascinating
first off when people write for browsers
do they target the mobile web or the
desktop web
well the overwhelming majority 72%
target both but despite all of our talk
about mobile first a vanishingly small
number of people target only mobile and
27% of us are getting away without
thinking about mobile at all that is
probably a legitimate number because
there's lots of applications we're just
never gonna be used on a phone like it's
some internal app admin application like
no one's ever gonna be running that on
their phone
but let's talk about native apps 46% of
JavaScript developers are writing native
apps
by a native app I mean an application
that runs directly on your desktop or
your phone I don't mean like you know
it's not a shortcut that's you know
actually a web app it's being either
transpiled or it's running directly with
full access to the file system like an
electron we were very careful about how
we phrased this question to make sure
that that was what people were answering
about this year because when we asked it
two years ago we used this ridiculously
vague language and everybody was like
well sometimes people look at it on
mobile so it's a mobile app anyway I'm a
very bad statistician anyway where are
we writing these native apps as you can
see the biggest group is mobile devs 35%
of respondents said that they are
writing native mobile apps that's of all
JavaScript developers 35% are writing
native mobile apps and 26% of
respondents are writing native desktop
agz
apps and a big chunk are doing both so
what are they using to do all this stuff
amongst the desktop developers 26% of
devs say that they write native desktop
apps and we have a bit of a puzzle here
because most of what we think of as
being desktop application development in
JavaScript happens an electron but only
21% of people say that they use
electrons so there's 5% who are writing
native desktop apps but not using
electron
I don't know what they're using if you
know what they're using please tell me
on the native mobile app side I measured
the popularity of frameworks for native
mobile apps I'm gonna explain how I
measured this in a second but for the
moment just believe me that green line
is all native native mobile app
development as you can see it's staying
pretty much constant but what's happened
is it's fragmented Cordova used to be
the only game in town that's the yellow
line but it is its shares going down in
favor of the red line which is react
native now they're both equal at about
19 percent of JavaScript developers but
if you're using some other framework to
do native mobile app development please
tell me about it the final where
question is about server side apps where
are we deploying them so 77% of us are
writing server side apps and
unsurprisingly docker and other
container applications like kubernetes
are everybody's jam everybody is
deploying that way these days but
deployment platforms like Heroku and
Neto Phi and stuff like that are
surprisingly popular and VMs are a
surprisingly unpopular choice I don't
know if I'm just old school but I sort
of think of VMs as being like the
default way that you deploy software but
if they're not anymore but the real
surprise in this number in these numbers
was service server lists has left out of
the sort of early adopter category and
at 33% this is a mainstream technology
now so now let's talk about what we're
using to do all of this as with the who
in the where sections this I'm going to
try and keep as factual as possible to
measure this stuff I use a metric called
share of registry it's a very useful
metric but it's also a somewhat
confusing metric it was the one that I
was just using so I'm going to explain
it briefly this is a graph of weekly
downloads from the NPM registry at the
moment we do a little under 12 billion
downloads every seven days and that
number has grown by 26 thousand percent
since NPM became a company and that
presents something of a problem first it
presents something of a scaling problem
but it also presents something of a
problem if you're trying to measure the
popular
of stuff because download numbers always
go up download numbers go up for
everything here's a graph of downloads
of some major front-end frameworks
they're all growing pretty fast in fact
everything in the registry is constantly
growing in terms of download numbers
even the shittiest package in the
registry is getting more and more
downloads every week just because more
and more people show up every week and
are like I don't know I'll download evil
package 1 this seems fine
so using absolute growth of downloads is
not a good way of measuring popularity
since Ted we're using relative
popularity as a percentage of all
downloads and that's what we call share
of registry so here are all the same
packages again using share of registry
as the metric instead and suddenly
what's going on is much clearer some
stuff is going up some stuff is staying
flat and some stuff is going down but
it's important to remember that going
down is only in relative terms so it
just means that you're not growing as
fast as everything else if you stay flat
on this graph that means that you grew
26,000 percent if you're going up on
this graph you grew faster than 26,000
percent so if you're going up at all on
this graph then you are really growing
so let's dig into these actual numbers
the story of front-end frameworks in
2019 is very simple and it is that react
has conquered the web react has more
than four times as many downloads as the
next most popular framework and there
has never been anything like this
popular in front-end frameworks part of
the reason for that is because react
isn't just a front-end framework in fact
it's not even a front-end framework it's
just a component model and that
component model is used by web apps but
as we saw with the native apps it's also
used in react native for mobile and it's
used in electron for desktop
applications but all this is just the
Downloads data what about the survey
where we asked actual people in our
survey 63% of JavaScript developers say
that they use react but using is a vague
term but what you know do you just use
it sometimes are using it you know just
to try stuff out so we asked a more
specific question 57% of people say that
they
right reacts themselves 6% say they use
react written by other people but more
interestingly 15% of people say that
they don't use react but are considering
it which means that they're even at 63
percent which is already an absurd
amount of adoption there still might be
room for react to continue to grow but
as you saw in that graph react growth
kind of seems like it might be slowing
down so it's not clear what's going to
happen next to the react to dig even
further we asked people how much they
write react inside the fifteen fifty
seven percent of people who write react
forty-nine percent said that they
primarily write react which means 26
percent of all NPM users are primarily
writing react a quarter of the of
JavaScript developers are primarily
writing react and if you include the
people who write at some of the time
that means 47 percent nearly half of
JavaScript developers are writing react
some or most of the time there has never
been a framework with that kind of
adoption it is changing the way web
development works
moving on to some other frameworks last
year I got into some trouble because I
took angular version 1 and angular
version 2 onwards and I called them both
angular and I put them together and I
didn't separate them out and I was
strenuously informed that that was
incorrect angular version 1 is now
called angularjs angular version 2
onwards is a completely different
framework that has nothing to do with
the first version and it's called
angular I think but that is a little bit
confusing I feel like I was justified
and not knowing that there that there's
two things called angular and they're
not the same anyway
as you can see angularjs has been in
decline since 2016 and angular 2 plus
has been in decline since 2017 but again
it's important to keep in mind this is
only in relative terms in absolute terms
both of these frameworks have more users
than they've ever had before in absolute
terms both of these frameworks are still
growing they're just not growing as fast
as everything else in the registry
angular remains an extremely popular
framework 37% of NPM users are using one
or the other version of angular
and 29% of NPM users say that they are
using the current version if you
extrapolate out that means there's
probably about 3 million people who do
angular which is definitely nothing to
sneeze at and probably means that it's
not going to go anywhere so let's look
at the next two most obvious framework
which is view view is the only major
framework other than react which is
strong showing strong positive growth
and it is very very positive share of
registry for view has more than doubled
in the last two years which means that
downloads grew more than a factor of 10
and our survey data backs this up 27% of
NPM users say that they are using view
which is up from 24% last year which
means that roughly the same number of
people who are using view as are using
the current version of angular one thing
that I haven't talked about so far is
web components and part of that is that
web components are built into browsers
so there isn't a share of registry
they're not downloading anything from
NPM to use web components but the other
reason is that they just don't seem to
be very popular we didn't ask about them
an NPM survey which was a mistake on my
part the state of j/s survey allowed
people to volunteer if they were using
web components but less than one percent
of web developers did so I'm not
ignoring web components but my data on
them is not very good at the moment the
people who build web components like the
people who work for browsers and build
web components they tell me that web
components are much more popular than I
believe but of course they would say
that moving from the front end to the
back end there has been a real
revolution previously if I was talking
about the back end I'd have talked about
frameworks like happy or ember and those
things are still around and they are
showing basically flat growth in the
registry which is to say 25000 percent
growth you know healthy but not
spectacular by the standards of the
registry but now everybody has moved to
writing rich front-end apps those
frameworks which are about providing
static views they're just not as popular
they're just not as much of a fit for
what we're doing instead what's happened
is that front-end framework enthusiasts
have realized that for performance
reasons they need to deliver
pre-rendered HTML from the server and so
they called it server-side rendering or
SSR and they invented a bunch of stuff
to do that which is to say they invented
backends so now all of the bet all of
the front-end frameworks are also
back-end frameworks they provide
collections of servers and routers that
make it easy to build a full server
using your favorite framework I don't
know about you but the idea that I can
just write a bunch of components and
throw them into exists an existing
framework that does all of the serving
and parsing and stuff for me that's
great but it's also super familiar I'm
pretty sure that is how PHP works
someday soon somebody is gonna like you
know do this huge flashy launch with an
amazing website and be like you can you
can build a website by just ft peeing
your react components to a server and
then the circle will be completes and we
will have finished reinventing PHP so
before I talk about these new SSR
frameworks
it's important to note that they are all
still pretty small here for comparison
is Express Express is a goddamn giant of
a package it used to be 1.5% of registry
downloads all by itself and while the
rest of the registry has sort of grown
up around it it is still very very big
all of the other frameworks that I'm
about to talk about they are that little
flat line at the bottom of this graph
but when you take Express out of the
picture the new picture is very
interesting at the top of our list is
Gatsby Gatsby uses react and it provides
a whole set of tools for hooking it up
to backends and providing easy
deployment methods for it got to be
snuck up on us in our previous survey we
didn't ask about Gatsby at all and this
year's survey 8% of people said that
they are using Gatsby
for comparison frameworks that we used
to talk about like happy and and amber
they're at like 5 percent and 4 percent
so Gatsby being at 8 percent means that
it is a real and serious framework that
is showing real growth and next comes a
trio of back-end frameworks which all
have nearly the same name in a way that
is not confusing or irritating at all
first up is next Jess it's another react
based framework
and our survey respondents love next j/s
about 9% of them say that they use it
the registry downloads data gives gatsby
the edge but it's clear that those two
things are both very popular and pretty
close together in terms of the number of
users then there is Knox
with au which is very much like next J s
but it's for view instead 5% of devs in
our survey say that they use it and it's
showing similar healthy growth and then
there's nest jeaious with an S which is
apparently also very much like next to
J's but it's for angular our survey
didn't ask about it because I only found
out about it quite recently but
extrapolating from its download data
probably about 2% of NPM users are using
Ness GS so closely related to all that
these front-end frameworks that are now
back-end frameworks is graph QL there
have been a couple of talks about graph
QL at this conference it's a pretty fun
technology it is the hot new way of
building api's that power all of this
stuff and as you can see graph QL score
library and two of its most popular
clients are all very very steadily
climbing and share of registry and this
climb is reflected in the survey data
the survey data says that 22% of
JavaScript developers are already using
graph QL but the really interesting
number is that half of NPM users 49% say
they are considering using graph QL
which means that 2019 is going to be a
very big year for that technology and
the final set of trend data we're going
to look at is the hottest trend of all
which is not writing JavaScript anymore
remember all of those non primary
JavaScript writers especially the ones
coming from typed languages like Java
and c-sharp and stuff this is how their
influence is showing up the biggest part
of this trend is typescript last year we
were caught completely by surprise when
we asked people how much if they use
typescript and 46% of them said yes this
year 63% of them said that they are
using typescript so we immediately asked
a bunch of a bunch more questions what
does using mean so it turns out that 15%
of people who say that they 15% of
people are using libraries that are
written in typescript and the main
culprit here is angular
angular is written in typescript so all
the angular users show up as typescript
users but they're not really writing
typescript so they're just using a thing
that is written in typescript it's
interesting that both react and ember
have type scripts now so the only major
framework that doesn't have some
typescript in it is view but even if you
say that you write typescript do you
mean that you write it all the time or
just to try it out within the typescript
developers 52% primarily write
typescript and another 34% write
typescript some of the time which means
that overall 36% of NPM users are
writing typescript somewhere all of the
time a third of javascript developers
don't write JavaScript anymore that is a
stunning change in the landscape in
which we're sitting incidentally one of
the features of typescript
is that it has type definition files and
those type definition files are hosted
under the types of scope which is on NPM
so I went looking to see exactly how
much of registry traffic is the type
scope and it turns out it's 2.5 percent
all by itself being constantly
downloaded by copies of vs code which
means that we're probably going to need
to have a chat with Microsoft about
their bandwidth bill the other part of
the not writing JavaScript trend is
webassembly
cast just gave a great talk about web
assembly and gave a whole bunch of good
reasons for using web assembly and its
place in the ecosystem but in case you
somehow were asleep for that web
assembly is a technology that lets you
take any compiled language and run it on
the web at near native speeds and
there's two interesting things about
that the first is obviously the speed
but the people who write web assembly
say that the much more interesting part
is the second part which is that it
gives you the ability to use existing
code written in other languages directly
on the web to me one of the most
exciting features of web assembly is
that when assembly modules are
interoperable with existing NPM modules
written in JavaScript so you can use a
tool like wisent pack which is for rust
or equivalent tools for other languages
and you can write code in those
languages publish it as a module to the
NPM registry and then just npm install
it into a JavaScript application and it
will work you won't even know that it's
not JavaScript's it'll just happen and
the way that I know that you won't know
it's JavaScript is because it already
happened it's is already happening the
call is coming from inside the house our
stats say that webassembly is still very
new only about 3 percent of people say
that they use it but you know at the
scale of NPM that means that about
300,000 people are using it and we found
that just 0.06 percent of packages in
the registry contain wasm but that is
about 600 packages and some of those are
very interesting but the big number for
webassembly is 54% that is how the
percentage of people who say that they
are considering using webassembly
webassembly is about to be very very big
so now we know who we are and what we're
using and those facts together can point
us towards explanations as to why this
is where I switch from facts to analysis
and by analysis I mean opinions but
first just a quick drink of water
because I'm going real slow and talking
a lot so for this next bit I need to
split up the room into two teams so
everybody on this side of the line you
are team a everybody on this side of the
line you are team B team a let me hear
it
team B team a team B fantastic I'm not
going to use that for anything it's just
to keep you awake after 30 minutes of
grass the other thing that I said that I
would do is I would give a pair of NPM
socks away but I didn't have time to
come up with any system for giving the
socks away is Shivani here there you are
Shivani had the bright idea of just
asking me on Twitter if she could get
the socks so she gets the sauce
[Applause]
so the first question to answer in the Y
section is why is JavaScript the most
popular programming language in the
world I think we can discard the idea
that it is the best designed language in
the world one possible answer is the NPM
registry a guy called Leo meyerovich for
his PhD did a study of in which he
researched why people pick programming
languages this is a very useful study
for answering this question so he was
asking you know is it features is its
speed is it because they're forced to by
their company
like what is it that makes somebody pick
a programming language and the number
one reason turned out to be open source
modules it turns out that if there is a
library that exists that helps you get
the job that you're trying to get done
done then you switch to the language in
which that library exists and because
the largest set of libraries is NPM that
means an enormous number of people are
moving to JavaScript because of all of
them libraries that are existing in NPM
and once you start doing that a positive
feedback loop kicks in more open source
libraries bring more users and those
users write more open source once about
every 15 minutes or so somebody on
Twitter sends me this picture but it's
not actually a bad analogy the NPM
registry has created a gravity well that
pulls in developers and every time a new
developer joins the JavaScript community
they increase the pull and this has
created the new type of JavaScript
developer The Reluctant JavaScript er
this used to be a very small group but
is now possibly a quarter or more of the
JavaScript community is reluctant Java
Scriptures they don't write Java scripts
because they like it they write
JavaScript because they have to and that
is bad that's bad for them because they
hate it but it's also bad for Java
scripts because people who don't like a
language are not going to write it well
and this happened before in 2009 and
2010 Ruby developers who were writing
web apps got sucked into the exploding
popularity of Java scripts and they
hated it
they told us that they hated it at the
time in the survey data they've made
very clear that they still hate it and
don't want to be writing JavaScript
some of them wanted some of them
attempted to solve this problem with
CoffeeScript which introduced a ton of
Ruby like features into JavaScript
CoffeeScript failed but honestly the
Ruby folks mostly one like JavaScript
these days modern JavaScript has a ton
of language features that are basically
copied from Ruby and typescript is
something like that pattern remember all
of those non primary JavaScript
developers who are working in typed
languages like Java and c-sharp a bunch
of people from those languages have come
to the JavaScript community and found
that they've missed types and typescript
gives them those types backing so given
the popularity of types and people using
those type languages and also
Microsoft's considerable backing to
typescript I don't think the typescript
is going to be the kind of failure that
CoffeeScript was in our survey 17% of
people who had heard of webassembly
said that the thing that they found most
interesting about web assembly was that
it allowed them to write a language
other than JavaScript and they preferred
doing that web assembly freeze web
developers and it frees web development
from JavaScript and the result will be
that a bunch of people will stop writing
JavaScript but that is not something to
be worried about
first not everybody will stop just the
people who hate it and second when
people writing web assembly are looking
for a way to share code with each other
the massive gravity well of the NPM
registry will make it obvious the best
place to share your web assembly modules
is also the NPM registry web assembly
will make JavaScript stronger by giving
it access to the best libraries no
matter what language they were written
it that is a tremendously exciting idea
the next question we're spending time on
is what the hell is going on with react
part of the explanation is that react
isn't a full web framework it has no
opinions about routing or data modules
like other frameworks do so as opinions
change about the best way to do routing
and data people don't have to abandon
react to be able to do that they can
just switch from you know flux to
reduction from Redux to whatever
next it's just a component model and it
creates truly reusable fully functioning
components if you've never seen quite
how well that can work here are two
examples of react components that you
can just npm install today two of the
most annoying and fiddly components a
color picker and a date picker and you
can just npm install them that my
friends has been the dream for 20 years
I don't want to have to implement a date
picker ever again and now I don't have
to other projects provide whole
libraries of excellent pre-built
components to use react toolbox does one
using Google's material design although
it's not like an official Google project
or anything and reach UI is an excellent
start on addressing accessibility
concerns and react by providing a
library of fully accessible react
components but now react can go even
further as you've already heard of this
conference react 16.8 introduced hooks
hooks are a new way of handling state in
react but from my perspective the most
interesting thing about hooks is that it
is very easy to add a whole bunch of
functionality to your application using
hooks by just npm installing them an
early promising demonstration of this is
react use which is a library that
provides a ton of functionality for the
like you know more dark and dangerous
corners of the Web API in your react app
by just npm installing the functionality
that you want to use with way less
effort on your part and this suggests an
enticing future where we can build web
apps at a whole new level of abstraction
all of these things together mean that
we won't have to think too hard about
what the server is or how it works or
even where it is and we can put existing
components together instead of having to
build them from scratch every time we
start a new project and each new
component added to the pile of
components inside of the NPM registry
will make it more attractive to use
those components again the same feedback
loop that created the NPM registry
itself could make react and react
components an unstoppable force that
changes web development forever but it's
not guaranteed
reiax growth seems to be
slowing down and view is showing a lot
of growth so is view the future will
react to decline and fall like every
framework ever before in the next couple
of years we get to find out in the
meantime
reacts dominance on the front end has
totally changed the back end as I showed
earlier frameworks that enable
server-side rendering of react apps are
now more popular than traditional
back-end frameworks so instead of
writing code for clients and servers we
just write code for clients and we get
the server to figure it out we
increasingly abstract away how code is
deployed and just give it away entirely
to serverless things or deployment
services building all apps is rich
front-end apps I'm not sure that that is
a good idea I'm not sure that that's
always the best kind of app that we can
build but it certainly is a popular idea
and as I've been pointing out popularity
has its own momentum at least one
browser maker is already working on
specific optimizations to the browser to
make react faster and last year I made
the case that react components or at
least some of the core parts of them
should become part of the browser so
that we can make our frameworks smaller
and we can make our frameworks faster
because we did that before we did that
with jQuery a lot of the api's that we
that were in jQuery are now just part of
the web api we think of ourselves as
having stopped using jQuery but we still
use jQuery every day we just don't need
to download a library to do it so I
stand by that I think some parts of
react are so good and so popular that at
this point they should probably be part
of the web so let's take all of these
trends and analysis and opinions and
weave them all together and make some
guesses about the future this is where I
go from slightly wrong to extremely
wrong first is a future I don't have to
guess about and that is NPM tink NPM
tink is a tremendously exciting leap
forward in package management it's a
package manager and a runtime and you
won't have to install packages anymore
you won't have to transpile type scripts
you won't have to think about whether
assembly you can just import stuff and
tink will figure it out so let's watch
that happen
will it have downloaded the whole video
what you're seeing is two modules in
this folder one is JavaScript and one is
wasum the main file is typescript index
TS we import that as 'm straight into
the typescript and then we use tink SH
to run that typescript we don't have to
do any transpiling we don't have to do
any loading there is no other code in
this folder tink just figures it out
that's amazing we don't have to do any
of that stuff anymore the ergonomics of
that are wonderful dan I dream of
tweeted recently about how vb6 is what
got him into programming and it's a
really great point because it's exactly
where it seems like all of this stuff is
going imagine a world where you can
build a web app without needing to know
all the details of how all of your
components work people hate on vb6
but at one point it was the world's most
programming popular programming language
and that's us now vb6 unlocked and
created a generation of programmers by
making programming very easy and
accessible for everyone that made it
very good and very popular think how
many more people could get to be web
developers if you could build a real and
useful web app by dragging and dropping
open-source components into it that
wouldn't make your job obsolete we would
still need everyone in this room to be
writing components but we would need a
room ten times this size to hold all of
the people who would be using the
components that we write it would be a
whole new level of abstraction it would
create a whole new type of web developer
and it would unlock a whole new sequence
and a whole new class of web apps that
currently it's too expensive for anyone
to build that is a tremendously exciting
idea and then you add to that mix web
assembly which it's still very early
days right now but you could bring every
useful library from every other language
and put them into the JavaScript
universe and make all of those libraries
interoperable with no performance hit
suddenly not only is it easier to build
these apps in JavaScript but what you
can build would be greatly expanded and
the last piece of the puzzle is all of
those native app developers that's
already nearly half of
take highly performant rich web apps and
then run them anywhere that you like on
desktops on phones on tablets on watches
on VR VR headsets on your shoes
JavaScript running everywhere absorbing
all of the other languages into a single
unified world of open-source components
built by an ever expanding and
increasingly diverse set of developers
there is no guarantee that that will
happen but I can imagine a world where
the thing that we currently call web
development just becomes the way that we
build software and after 23 years of
watching web development change and grow
no time has ever been more exciting to
be a web developer and you my friends
and colleagues are perfectly placed to
become part of that change the web is an
amazing force for good and evil it is a
toy and the tool it's a playground and
it's a marketplace it is alternately
amazing and terrifying and its power we
can do so much good and we can do so
much harm but I choose to believe that
in the long run we will collectively
decide to do more things that help the
world than hurt it we have all made
mistakes that have hurt people I know
that I have but I believe that in the
course of time our good decisions will
outweigh our bad decisions and the web
will grow forever I hope what I've
shared with you today has helped you see
where you are and what you can do I hope
that's helped motivate you and make you
curious I hope you've had a fantastic
jeaious cough
I certainly have and thank you all so
much for your time and attention